- For courage, not
complacency, is our need today,
leadership, not salesmanship.
And the only valid test of leadership
is the ability to lead
and lead vigorously.
- Courage was the quality
- The entire nation.
- that my grandfather,
President Kennedy, most admired.
And the Profiles in
Courage Award celebrates
political leaders who demonstrate
that courage in our time.
- This is the moment when
we know what we must do,
when we know what is right.
We cannot walk away from this truth.
- Mayor Landrieu decided
to proceed with relocating
four Confederate monuments
in the city of New Orleans
despite facing intense
criticism for that decision,
and it was a very heated moment,
heated political moment for him,
and he decided to not
only remove the statues,
but to candidly and compassionately
address his city and our
country and offer an explanation
and give historical context about
why that decision was the right one.
- This is not about politics.
It's not about blame.
It's not about retaliation.
This is not about a naive quest
to solve all of our problems at once.
- In a year marked by
continued racial strife
and conflict and absent national
leadership on this issue,
the mayor took it upon himself
to offer an example of political courage
on an issue that could not
be more important today.